♫
>> Tucker: NEWLY RELEASED
TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE DON’T
SIMPLELY FROM IMPLICATIONS
TO THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
THEY ARE EMBARRASSING FOR
THE FBI.
THEY TELL US MORE THAN MAYBE
WE WANTED TO KNOW.
ONE TEXT EXCHANGE STRZOK
REFERS TO THE VIRGINIA
CITIZENS HE DESERVES AS SERVES T
HILLBILLIES HE MISSPELLS THE
WORD.
NOT ELECTING MCCABE’S WIFE.
STRZOK ADULT MALE MESSAGE
PAGE IN ALL CAPS OMG THIS IS
F’ING TERRIFYING HE
SQUEALED.
PAGE REPLIED OMG I AM SO
DEPRESSED.
OBVIOUSLY ARTICULATE GROUP.
A FEW DAYS LATER PAGE WROTE
THIS I BOUGHT ALL THE
PRESIDENT’S MEN I FIGURED I
NEED TO BRUSH UP ON
WATERGATE.
WHAT OUR TASK WAS
REMAINS UNCLEAR.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST.
HE HAS SEEN THESE TEXTS AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
UNEDUCATED HILLBILLIES, HUH?
>> OMG, TUCKER.
LOL.
I THINK LAST TIME THEY CAME
UP ON YOUR SHOW JOHN
REWRITTEN BY TEEN BEAT.
I’M GLAD TO SAY THEY HAVE
MANAGED TO KEEP THAT UP.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND -- JUST
TO BE SERIOUS FOR A MOMENT
NOBODY RESIGNS IN WASHINGTON
UNLESS THEY ARE CAUGHT UP IN
ME TOO.
LISA PAGE PETER STRZOK ONE
MEETING WEARING HARVEY
WEINSTEIN’S BATH ROBE.
HE IS OUT.
ABSENT THAT NOBODY RESIGNS.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY THESE
TWO ARE STILL IN GOVERNMENT
SERVICE?
WE WERE ACCUSED OF BEING
BIGOTS BY JOY REID AND HER
CHUMS AT MSNBC A WEEK OR TWO
BACK.
THESE PEOPLE ACTUALLY ARE
BIGOTS.
THEY THINK OF VIRGINIANS AS
HILLBILLIES AND ROMANIANS AS
SLEAZY.
ONE POINT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS GUCCIFER BIG
INTERNET GUY IN ROMANIA
DESCRIBED AS SLEAZY ROMANIAN
AND LISA PAGE TEXT STRZOK
BACK ALL ROMANIANS ARE
SLEAZY.
COMBINE THE CROOKEDNESS OF
RUSSIANS WITH THE
ENTITLEDNESS OF ITALIANS.
WHAT’S THAT ONE, TWO, THREE
NATION STATES WHOSE ENTIRE
POPULATIONS HAVE JUST BEEN